nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
direction Taïwan à 180 km au large de la
Chine continentale Lille est sous une
pression croissante de son puissant
voisin qui considère le pays comme une
province chinoise chez une Ping le
président chinois envisage le recours à
la force et prépare son armée en
multipliant les provocations militaires
le spectre d'une guerre à l'Ukrainienne
entre les 23 millions de taïwanais qui
n’ignorent pas non plus la manière dont
Pékin a repris le contrôle de Hong Kong
Cyril Payen bonjour pendant près de
trois semaines vous avez arpenté Taïwan
à la rencontre des acteurs de ce bras de
fer géopolitique jamais l'attention n'a
été aussi forte pourquoi ecoutez c'est
vrai que il y a le spectre de l'Ukraine
vous l'avez dit qui qui pèse beaucoup et
il faut dire que la reconduction pour le
troisième mandat le 20 octobre dernier
au Congrès du Parti communiste chinois
carcondu pour une sorte de président
éternel chez shinping et bien il lui
donner dans une de ces prérogatives ne
s'est priorités ce qu'il appelle la
réunification entre la Chine populaire
et Taïwan donc on peut c'est vrai
craindre un peu pour l'avenir en tout
cas c'est ce qu'on va voir dans le film
les Taïwanais sont très préoccupés par
les nouvelles directives chinoises alors
on vous retrouve juste après la
diffusion de ce document Taïwan la
prochaine bataille un reportage de Cyril
Payen aliéré Liline Ricordeau et Jérôme
Bonnefoy
[Musique]
ces jours de fête nationale la Taipei le
gouvernement de la République de Chine
célèbre les 111 ans d'un petit État qui
n'a jamais autant été de son histoire
récente sous la pression de l'invasion
militaire
le torchon brûle entre Pékin et Taïwan
et le monde retient son souffle
la communauté internationale la
parfaitement compris
renforcer la sécurité de Taïwan signifie
aussi et surtout renforcer et assurer la
paix régionale comme les valeurs de la
démocratie la destruction de la
démocratie taïwanaise serait une
terrible défaite pour les libertés et
les démocraties mondiales protéger notre
territoire défendre notre nation ne peut
être et ne sera jamais la seule
responsabilité de l'armée chaque citoyen
est le protecteur de la nation
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous
monsieur chain aujourd'hui
ça n'a aucun sens comme pour plus de la
moitié des 23 millions de taïwanais
chaîne est un fervent défenseur de
l'indépendance
aujourd'hui la question de notre défense
est très importante mon pays est menacé
et pour moi cela passe avant les
questions politiques nous devons d'abord
protéger Taïwan c'est la priorité des
priorités
Jane rêve de vivre dans la République de
Taïwan et en dépit des discours martiaux
de la présidence ce jour-là il reproche
au gouvernement de ne pas être plus
offensif vis-à-vis de Pékin
cette chaussure c'est la pression
chinoise sur nous
ce qu'elle veut dire et ce que je pense
aussi bien sûr c'est que nous à Taïwan
nous sommes perpétuellement écrasés par
la Chine
la guerre de Taïwan aura-t-elle vraiment
lieu la Chine populaire sous impulsion
du président Chichin ping va-t-elle se
lancer dans son projet de réunification
la réunification un contresens
historique pour les Taïwanais qui ne se
sont jamais aussi peu senti chinois
depuis que les préparatifs d'un conflit
menacent leur île la défense de Taïwan
justement c'est devenue l'obsession de
cet homme Robertsau l'une des plus
grandes fortunes de l'île une fortune
qui l'a décidé de mettre au service de
ce qu'il appelle la résistance à
l'oppression de Pékin
je viens en fait de publier un article
où je donne des clés pour que l'opinion
soit plus concernée par la question de
l'indépendance de Taïwan vis-à-vis de la
Chine
je pense que c'est important en ce
moment je suggère aussi que nous
devrions commencer par changer de nom de
ne plus s'appeler République de Chine
mais Taïwan tout simplement
nous nous appelons Chine et à Pékin il
s'appelle Chine aussi cela génère de la
confusion vous comprenez et c'est
vraiment une question de sécurité
nationale il faut être clair nous sommes
un État indépendant
mais que répondez-vous Robert à vos
détracteurs à ceux qui vous reprochent
d'aller trop loin avec ce genre de
discours
ce sont des lâches
ils ont peur de la Chine ils craignent
que si nous changeons de nom que les
Chinois vont se fâcher etc que c'est une
provocation
mais non c'est juste une manière de
clarifier la situation nous sommes une
nation à part entière et nous le sommes
depuis des centaines d'années et cela
doit être reconnu par le monde entier
nous retrouvons Roberts Sao chez lui
c'est l'annexion musclée de Hong Kong en
2019 qu'il a décidé engagé des millions
de dollars pour préparer les Taïwanais à
l'invasion toute théorique pour
l'instant du voisin chinois
vous savez les gens ici sont trop
sereins
c'est sans doute parce qu'ils ont
tellement de fois entendu cette histoire
du loup qui attaquait
et qu'ils n'ont pas vu
sont comme paralysés
et ce d'autant plus que la propagande
chinoise a envahi les médias ici
mais le message qu'elle fait passer
partout c'est que toute forme de défense
de Taïwan est inutile
Robert Sao s'est rallié la jeune garde
de la politique Taïwan
fait partie de ces candidats woodan pie
sans parti sans étiquette une manière de
récuser la politique traditionnelle
taïwanaise axée sur le fragile statu quo
avec Pékin
pourquoi vous êtes-vous engagé en
politique
parce qu'il faut que notre génération
comprenne que nous devons impérativement
stopper toute forme de dépendance à la
Chine
[Musique]
bien sûr notre plateforme repose sur la
défense de nos valeurs démocratiques et
nous sommes unis pour résister à toute
forme de pression extérieure comme la
menace de l'invasion chinoise
nous avons tous
vu en Ukraine il y a une mobilisation
générale dans les villes et les
campagnes contre l'invasion russe les
Ukrainiens ont fait le choix de vivre et
de mourir pour leur patrie nous devons
faire pareil aujourd'hui les Taïwanais
doivent avoir des représentants
politiques pour renforcer les alliances
avec les pays amis contre l'ennemi de
l'étranger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voici la petite île de Kidman
l'hypothétique ligne de front de cette
guerre de Taïwan que tout le monde
craint et dont personne ne sait si elle
aura lieu ici la Chine populaire est à
moins de 2 km les gratte-ciel et les 5
millions d'habitants de la ville côtière
de chamen donne une idée du rapport de
force
c'est assez étrange presque excitant
d'être la cyprès de pouvoir si
clairement observer la Chine depuis ici
ça ne fait pas peur non parce que nous
sommes liés à la Chine dans nos vies
qu'on le veuille ou non
la guerre bien sûr nous avons tous ici
peur de la guerre la paix est une valeur
universelle n'est-ce pas mais jusqu'à
présent la Chine n'a jamais voulu
renoncer à dominer Taiwan par la force
pour Pékin c'est une question
d'hégémonie de suprématibilité
comme une énième référence à l'Ukraine
Kidman est souvent en surnommée la
Crimée de Taïwan c'est le poste avancé
le plus exposé situé du côté chinois du
détroit c'est ainsi nous sommes sur
cette petite île en face du continent
chinois et ce depuis des siècles nous ne
pouvons rien faire pour changer notre
position géographique notre pays est une
démocratie libérale quand l'autre con
comme nous le savons maintenant est un
état à partir unique un État autoritaire
la liberté d'expression et de croyances
l'existence des partis politiques sont
interdits je pense que vivre où je suis
ne me rend pas moins heureux que de
vivre en Chine continentale
retour même au plus haut sommet de
l'État on laisse entendre qu'il faut se
préparer au pire que pensez-vous d'un
homme comme Robertsau est-ce que son
engagement est important
défendre Taïwan quand vous regardez ce
qui se passe en Ukraine n'est donc pas
uniquement la responsabilité du
gouvernement
si la population est formée avec des
équipements et des connaissances pour la
défense du pays
je pense que la Chine va au devant de
graves problèmes en cas d'attaque donc
en ce qui concerne Robert Sao son
plaidoyer ses idées et ses aides
généreuses nous ne pouvons que les
encourager
les civils taïwanais à l'école de guerre
ils sont désormais des milliers à suivre
ces formations financées par Robertsau
qui entend mobilisé une force de
défensive de 300 000 volontaires
je suis là pour être prêt à la guerre je
veux savoir quelle mesure la Chine va
prendre si elle nous attaque il faut que
les Taïwanais sachent que la Chine est
clairement notre ennemi les Chinois ont
déjà commencé la guerre de l'information
et beaucoup de taïwanais ne connaissent
pas la vérité
[Musique]
nous retrouvons chaînes le militant pour
l'indépendance de Taïwan il vit dans le
quartier de one Roja dans le sud de
Taipei avec ses deux filles et son
épouse professeur de français
est-ce que Taïwan fait vraiment partie
intégrante de la Chine la doctrine
communiste exploite la confusion
historique et c'est devenu un compromis
international les États-Unis soutiennent
notre démocratie mais ils ne disent pas
qu'ils soutiennent l'indépendance de
Taïwan ils disent simplement qu'il ne
s'y oppose pas je pense que c'est à nous
de choisir de faire le choix de
l'indépendance ou non
parce que sentimentalement chinois ouais
mais en fait on a on ne peut que avoir
qu'un seul pays c'est Taïwan
[Musique]
les premières traces d'occupation
humaine de Taïwan remonte à plus de 30
000 ans
alors que ce berceau de population de
l'Asie et de l'Océanie vit aujourd'hui
sous la menace d'une des plus puissantes
armées de la planète les Taïwanais
continuent de vivre en se préparant à la
guerre
[Musique]
et on retrouve Cyril païen en plateau de
retour de Taïwan ce pays qui n'en est
pas vraiment un Taïwan a un statut très
particulier Cyril écoutez Antoine le
manque qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il y a
une forme de paradoxe ce que les
autorités taïwanaise dénoncent comme un
tabou diplomatique c'est à dire que tout
le monde connaît Taïwan la communauté
internationale commerce essentiellement
et beaucoup avec ta voix dans le sait
mais ne le reconnaît pas
diplomatiquement c'est donc une sorte de
trou noir diplomatique et je peux vous
dire qu'ici dans les 24 millions de
taiwanais avec qui on a pu passer
quelques temps mais on le vit très très
mal de temps qui est cette menace
pregnante du géant chinois qui est à
quelques dizaines de kilomètres lors de
leur côté on l'a vu dans votre reportage
seul une poignée de taiwanais
soutiennent la réunification avec la
Chine je vous propose d'en écouter un
bien sûr il a les amis Taïwan qui sont
pro la demande il y en a beaucoup c'est
vrai mais il y a aussi beaucoup pour
l'autre pour notre côté pour la
réunification avec la Chine continentale
si on veut programmer la dame danse
selon tous les expériences historiques
il faut une guerre nous avons maintenant
une en un ensemble très très
Ukraine et la Russie on veut vraiment
éviter la guerre donc il faut
chier donc il est un pays de system mais
nous nous avons notre proposition c'est
une confédération ou une fédération on
ne peut pas permettre
la guerre
détruit tous nos succès électronique
politique qui sont conçus depuis déjà 66
ans
alors voilà pour les tenants d'une forme
de rattachement en tout cas à la Chine
Cyril cette guerre se prépare depuis des
décennies avec des hauts et des bas
qu'est-ce qu'un pays à peine plus grand
que la Belgique peut espérer
militairement parlant face à ce géant
qui est son grand voisin la Chine et
qu'est-ce que des pays comme les
États-Unis peuvent faire en cas
d'attaque écouter c'est la question un
million de dollars Antoine et que je
peux vous dire que beaucoup de stratèges
dans le monde se posent puisqu'on pense
que ce conflit va arriver d'une manière
ou d'une autre et les dernières
déclarations du président chinois qui je
le rappelle a été investi pour un
troisième mandat en octobre les
premières choses qu'il est dites c'est
que nous allons réunifier avec ce que
vous avez dit c'était très justement
c'est à dire ce que Taïwan qui est
considéré comme une province la question
qui va être cet invasion va-t-il s'agir
de nouvelles guerres mondiale c'est très
possible sur le papier mais il est vrai
que au regard de ce qui s'est passé en
Ukraine tijing Bing pourrait prendre
l'avantage et il n'est pas certain que
malgré les promesses nombreuses je parle
des pays voisins ou les États-Unis
ce cours de Taïwan que tout cela soit
devienne une réalité c'est une grande
crainte des taïwanais c'est pour ça que
ils savent il se prépare tranquillement
mais il se prépare résolument à une
possible guerre voilà Taïwan la
prochaine bataille avec ce point
d'interrogation évidemment que nous que
nous gardons dans notre titre merci
beaucoup Cyril Payen c'est la fin de ce
magazine merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau numéro de reporter sur France
[Musique]